Hey, hallo zu neuen Folge-Podcast-Ufro. Hey, hallo, herzlich willkommen. Wir waren lange weg, jetzt sind wir wieder da. Wir sind so ein bisschen verstreut. Es ist so, Stefan sitzt bei sich zu Hause in seiner Kölner Wohnung im Erdgeschoss, hat natürlich die Wollwegflasche in der Hand, da gibt er erstmal Gas, da macht er sich erstmal bereit. Ich sitze in Hamburg, das heißt, wir haben eine klassische Fernfolge. Ich glaube, wir haben seit fast hundert Folgen keine Fernfolge mehr gemacht. Hallo, bist du noch da? Hallo, Stefan? Ja, erzähl ich dich wieder. Kannst du winken, wenn du mich hörst? Ja, das ist nämlich so, das muss man bei Skype immer mal machen, ab und zu. Man muss auch sagen, dass Skype sich auch wirklich einfach nicht verbessert, ne? Also hat sich einfach noch nie verbessert. Es fing an gut, da war es so state of the art, aber dann ist es nicht mehr der Zeit gegangen, muss man sagen. Es ist so eine Konstante in meinem Leben und ich glaube, deren Unterschrift ist, deren Logo ist auch, Hallo? Hey? Hast du... Ja, ja, ich hör dich. Hier könnt ihr euch unterbrechen, wenn ihr eure Familie aus dem Ausland anruft. Ich glaube, er hört mich nicht. Ich glaube, er hört mich nicht. Oma, die Kamera ist falsch rum. Oma, ich sehe unter den Tisch gerade. Oma. Ja, ich glaube, die Kameras, die am iPhone sind, die vorne, dass es seitdem es vorne und hinten Kameras gibt, glaube ich, wurden Calls mit der Familie, ich mache die Kameras aus, auch noch anstrengender. Weil ich glaube, Oma und Opa verstehen das Konzept von Facecam auch nicht. Also die Kamera, die zu einem zeigt, kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, dass das Konzept sich überträgt in Generationen. Nee, glaube ich auch nicht. Aber ich weiß nicht, ist ein bisschen anders. Ich musste mir extra ein Mikrofon ausleihen. Ich hoffe, ich habe nicht zu sehr, heil, heil. Ich glaube, es ist schon ein bisschen Florentin wohnt jetzt in einer Kirche, in so einer großen, entweiten Kirche. Aber sie wurde nicht von einem Pfarrer entweigt, sie wurde von Florentin entweigt, als er die Kirche betreten hat. Vor allem, du warst ja schon oft in meiner Kölner Wohnung, die kennst du ja wie deine Lieblingshose, wie deine Sommerhose. Du, ich weiß, wo der Schrank mit den Cornflakes ist, ich kenne mich da aus. Ich will dir mal ein paar Details
zu meiner Hamburger Wohnung präsentieren,
weil ich glaube, da haben wir noch gar nicht über drüber oft gesprochen.
Ein paar Fun Facts.
Fun Fact Nummer drei
der Hamburger Wohnung von Florentin,
seine WG-Wohnung.
Ich dachte, es fängt nach fünf an, aber okay.
Nee, nee, nee, so glaube ich nicht.
Schlapp es dir.
Jeder einzelne Lichtschalter
Jeder einzelne Lichtschalter.
Ja, ich höre dich.
Hallo?
Ja, ja.
Du warst gerade weg.
Ich bin schon noch da.
Hast du nichts gesagt oder warst du weg?
Ich habe nichts gesagt.
Ist auch immer gut.
Kannst du blinzeln, wenn du mich hörst?
Okay, alles klar, gut.
Ich fang nochmal an.
Jeder Nochmal? Jetzt hast du mir reingesprungen.
Jeder einzelne Lichtschalter.
Okay.
Achtung,
pass auf.
Platz nochmal rein.
Jeder einzelne Lichtschalter in dieser Wohnung ist stufenlos einstellbar. Lass das sinken. Jeder einzelne Lichtschalter ist... Ist der Satz schon vorbei? Ja. Das war schon vorbei. Ich sag ab jetzt immer over, wenn der Satz vorbei ist. Ja. Stufenlos einstellbar. Also du hast so Schienregler. Ja,, so diese romantisches Licht. Dimmer, genau, das war das Wort, das ich gesucht habe. Jeder einzelne Lichtschalter ist ein Dimmer. Du gehst in die Küche, Dimmer an. Bad, Dimmer. Schön Wohnzimmer, Dimmer. Und du hast ja, die Lichtschalter sind ja sehr in dich eingebrannt. Also ich weiß nicht, ob du es schon kennst, wenn du in eine neue Wohnung einziehst und du hast immer noch die alten Lichtschalter und haust dann ständig auf Stellen an der Wand, wo nichts ist. Weißt du, ob du das kennst? Auf jeden Fall. Das ist hier ganz besonders so, weil hier ist immer alles ein Dimmer, was man so seitlich drehen muss, wie so ein Flaschendeckel. Und wenn du aber noch im Kölner Mindset bist, dann kommst du mit einem Gast in die Küche und sagst, hier ist die Kü die Küche und dann haust du auf diesen Dimmer drauf und es passiert gar nichts. Und dann hast du erstmal so ein paar Sekunden, werde ich gerade entführt, ist das deine Wohnung? Ich habe das auch mittlerweile, weil ich kenne das ja auch, und zwar kennt man das ja vor allem bei Bädern. Da kennt ja jeder die Stelle, wo man hinhauen muss. Du gehst in dein Bad rein, Klo, klassisch Klo, und du haust außen rechts gegen die Wand. Jeder hat die Höhe, jeder hat diesen Schwung auch drauf, diesen leichten Klaps gegen die Wand und dann geht man rein aufs Klo. Jetzt bin ich umgezogen in ein neues Büro und es fühlt sich erstmal viel besser an, als das alte Büro, die BTF, wo ich vorher gearbeitet habe, das alte Büro, das war einfach, das war kein Büro, das war, das hatte so ein Loft-Flair. Man hat sich immer gefühlt, man hat sich kreativ gefühlt. Jetzt aber bin ich in so einem klassischen Bürogebäude eingezogen, wo früher war da Good Times, die den Trödeltrupp produziert haben. Und es ist noch diese alte, also jemand hat gesagt, es spukt so ein bisschen, ich finde auch, es spukt so, da wurde nämlich das gute Fernsehen getötet. Aber ich kann mir vorstellen, dass sie ein sehr sauberes Gebäude zurückgelassen haben, oder? Ja, auf jeden Fall. Also perfekt geräumt, muss man sagen. Perfekt gedrückt. Da lag nichts mehr rum. Kein Drucker, kein Scanner, gar nichts. Alles weg. Und es wird nicht so, der Geist des guten Fernsehens schwebt noch ein bisschen rum. Und dann tatsächlich ist es so, wenn man in das Bad reingeht, es wurde nämlich nicht so viel Gedanken gemacht über die Räume. Das heißt, die Räume wurden teilweise einfach errichtet, die Wände sind auch dann sehr dünn und die Lichtschalter passen nicht zu dem Raum, in dem sie sind. Das ist ein Problem. Und dann gehe ich immer ins Klo rein, hau außen gegen diesen Schalter, aber das ist aus Versehen, das ist der Generalschalter des ganzen Büros. Und ich bin der Einzige, der immer das passiert, dass immer wenn ich ins Klo gehe, den Generalschalter anmache und so Moving-Scheinwerfer gefühlt, einfach wirklich helle Scheinwerfer angehen und das ganze Büro erleuchten. Was immer sehr unangenehm ist, weil immer alle sehen, dass ich aufs Klo gehe, die ganze Zeit. Vor allem, warum gibt es überhaupt einen Generallichtschalter? Warum hat man immer gesagt, okay, wir brauchen einen Masterlichtschalter, falls alle anderen nicht mehr wissen, wo sie sind, drück den. Das ist so ein Power-Move, wenn du merkst, der Elektriker, der kommt, du willst sagen, dass du ihm überlegen bist und dass du sozial über ihm stehst, dann musst du sagen, und können sie auch einen Generalschalter bauen und so. Das ist die Herausforderung, die man ihm gibt. Macht der Lichtschalter, dreht der denn alle Lichterschalter um? Also du hast zehn Lichtschalter im Büro und fünf davon stehen auf Plus und fünf auf Minus und jetzt drückst du den Generalschalter. Dreht sich dann alles um oder wird alles auf, also das ist ja ganz komisch.
Das ist die, ich nenne sie mal die Fett-Schreibfrage,
weil wenn du einen Satz
schreibst und es ist bereits ein Buchstabe
fett und du machst dann, du markierst
den ganzen Satz und drückst auf fett, wird dann
alles fett, wird nur das fett, was
vorher nicht fett war und der fette Buchstabe
wird wieder normal. Noch fetter?
Der Jojo-Effekt. Wo soll das alles hingehen?
Diese kleine Einführung gibt es in
Schalltechnik. Funfact Nummer zwei von Florentin Will.
Vielen Dank. Der Stab wird wieder normal. Noch fetter. Der Jojo-Effekt. Wo soll das alles hingehen? Diese kleine Einführung gibt es in Schalltechnik. Fun Fact Nummer zwei von Flonti Will. Fun Fact Nummer zwei. Der Raum, in dem ich gerade bin. Mein Zimmer in dieser WG. Wie lange hast du diesen Ausschnitt geframed, in dem du gerade zu sehen bist? Weil man muss sagen, es ist so ein David Lynch-artiger Ausschnitt, den man nicht gerade sieht. Ja, das Problem ist immer, ich habe ja meinen Monitor und ich hab meinen Laptop. Und mein Laptop ... Also, ich sitze vor meinem Monitor, aber ich sitze nicht vor meinem Laptop. Immer wenn man mit dem Skypt guckt, guckst du nicht in die Kamera. Du guckst wie ein perfekt gestageter Talking Head. Du guckst immer zum Redakteur, zum Redakteur vorbei. Ja, weil ich schau ja auf dich und du bist auf dem Monitor. Aber du bist nicht auf meinem Laptop. Das ist auch oft so, in Köln steht mein Laptop direkt neben mir. Das heißt, ich bin der Einzige, den man im Profil sieht. Wenn ich eine Skype-Konferenz alle sieht, sieht man frontal, nur mich im Profil. Und man denkt immer so, ist das eine Münze? Ist das eine entsprechende Münze? Was macht der Typ da? Wie so ein Speaking Jazz, wo man jemanden von der Seite reinframed. Und ab und zu kommen dann die Ziele. So wie so ein Schatten-S-Schattenspiel. Platz Nummer zwei der Funfacts der Hamburger Wohnung von Florentins WG. In dem Zimmer, in dem ich mich gerade befinde, gibt es ... zwanzig Steckdosen. Wuhu! Zwanzig, das ist kein Witz, das ist keine Übertreibung, ich könnte dir die Idee davon zeigen. Zwanzig Steckdosen. Davon sind teilweise manche auf Kopfhöhe, manche unter der Decke und ich habe manche Winkel, wo beide Seiten nochmal drei Stück haben. Das ist völlig absurd. Ich habe das Gefühl, das gesamte Stromnetz Hamburgs fließt einfach bei mir zusammen. Also jeder Strom muss erstmal über mich. Das ist ja wirklich perfekt. Vielleicht war da vorher ein Lampenladen drin oder sowas. So ein Showroom, wo man Lampen angeschlossen hat sehr viel. Ich wohne auch in der ehemaligen Hausmeisterwohnung und das ist jetzt exakt wie alle anderen Wohnungen auch. Aber es wurde betont sehr häufig, als ich eingezogen bin. Ja, auf einmal ich habe das Gefühl, der Elektriker hat noch nie was von Verteilern gehört, der diesen Raum gemacht hat. Naja, man braucht schon 20 Steckdosen, oder? So eine schöne Lampe, irgendwie noch so ein Regal. Ach, Vater, ich dussel. Oh, sorry. Er dachte, er wäre sehr clever, aber dann wurde er Verteiler. Es ist wie Graham Bell. Graham Bell hat das Telefon erfunden und wollte, dass man sich mit Ahoy meldet und dachte, es wäre cool und witty und lustig. Aber dann kam Edison, das Arschloch, und hat gesagt, ja, wie wäre es, wenn wir uns alle mit Hello melden, wie wir uns eh schon die ganze Zeit begrüßen, und am Ende hat sich Edison durchgesetzt. Womit, deswegen hat sich Edison durchgesetzt? Und deswegen sagen wir alle Hello, wenn wir am Zens Telefon gehen, weil Edison den unkreativeren Vorschlag gebracht hat. Okay, dann rufen wir jetzt Graham Bell an und gucken mal, wie er antwortet, okay? Aber heisst Graham Bell. Bellnen Sie kurz... Telefone waren damalsissen. Sorry, Sie sind kurz ab. Hören Sie mich wieder.
Können Sie kurz...
Telefone waren damals besser.
Ja, hallo.
Muss man wirklich mal sagen.
Muss man diese Videotelefonie.
Das ist doch Quatsch, man muss sich nicht dabei sehen.
Sie haben recht, Bell.
Also, noch mal, es gab damals auf diesem Marktplatz die allgemeingültige Abstimmung
und es stand 18 zu 2, meine Frau und ich haben für Ahoi gestimmt. So, nicht mal mein bester Freund hat für Ahoi gestimmt, okay? Nicht mal mein bester Freund. Und dann kommt Edison vorbei, diese Abstimmung hat sich nicht mal gegeben, aber dann hat er den Gegenvorschlag eingereicht. Am letzten Tag der Frist hat er den Gegenvorschlag eingereicht. Ich dachte mir, warum sollte man überhaupt einen Gegenvorschlag einreichen? Ich hab mich auch schon geärgert, dass ich dem Volk die Chance eingeräumt habe, einen Gegenvorschlag einzureichen, okay? Dann kommt der mit Hello um die Ecke. Wer soll denn gewinnen gegen Hello? Hallo, sind Sie noch da? Ich hab's jetzt gerade nicht gehört. Sie waren kurz weg. Aber können Sie sich nicht vorstellen, dass man sich vielleicht meldet mit Bell, Bell, Bell? Who do we have here? Oder mit Highway to Bell? Ja, nicht so schlecht. Graham, Mr Bell? Nicht so schlecht. Ich habe auch die Glühbirne auf Allo. Über welchen haben Sie jetzt gelacht? Haben Sie über Highway to Bell gelacht? Bell. Haben Sie über Highway to Bell gelacht? Bell, Bell, Bell habe ich noch gelacht. Highway to... Wie bitte? Highway to Bell! Jetzt ist er komplett weg. Ich habe ihn gar nicht mehr. Nee, der ist jetzt weg. Das ist interessant, dass sich das wirklich gar nicht verbessert hat. Vor allem seit dem Dosentelefon ist es wirklich bergab gegangen. Dosentelefon ist direkt keine Latenz. Wir könnten mit einem Dosentelefon besser aufnehmen als mit Skypads. Hattest du wirklich schon mal ein Dosentelefon verwendet? Mein Leben lang denke ich mir, das ist eine geniale Idee. Und funktioniert das wirklich so gut? Nicht so genial. Also hat das diese kristallklare Klangqualität, wie man immer hört? Ja, vor allem müsste mal jemand Dosentelefon mit Video, also quasi FaceTime-Dosentelefonie erfinden, das wäre mal was. Dosenvideo? Ja, nee, ich glaube, sobald diesesur irgendwas berührt, oder vor allem Vögel sind doch ein Problem
für Dosen-Telefon, oder? Vögel
lieben Leinen, so freihängende
Leinen, wo man sich draufsetzen kann. Das ist schon mal
das erste große Problem.
Und solange es nicht funktioniert,
einer der vielleicht besten Gags bei den Simpsons,
als das Haus überwacht wurde
vom FBI, haben die natürlich diese Schnur
angezapft vom FBI.
Und dann führt so eine Schnur von der Schnur in so einen FBI-Van. Nicht so schlecht. Das ist schon sehr lustig. Aber wo wir gerade bei Lichtern waren, ganz sorry, ganz kurz. Wir machen das knackig. Ich ballere rein, wo ich Platz finde, okay, und dann machst du vielleicht Platz eins. Du hast eine Menge Redebedarf, wir haben zwar auch nicht gesprochen. Ich weiss, es ist echt hart. Neulich ist mir was passiert, wo wir gerade bei Lichtschaltern waren. Und zwar, ich habe ja keine Lichtschaltern mehr. Ich habe ja gesagt, seitdem ich eine Alexa habe.
Ist angegangen. Sie ist angegangen. Aber seitdem ich...
Du machst Licht aus.
Alexa, stopp, Alexa, stopp! Alexa, mach das Licht im Schlafzimmer an.
Alek... da... da... Wow. Alexa, mach das Licht im Schlafzimmer an. Alexa, da. Wow. Alexa, mach das Licht im Schlafzimmer aus. So. Ah, ist auch ein Dimmer. Und das habe ich jetzt gemacht. Ja, und zwar habe ich die, weil die sehr hell ist, diese Lampe, habe ich die auf 50% gestellt, weil das auch mein Nachtlicht ist. Jetzt ist aber neulich mal, irgendwann habe ich den Router ausmachen müssen, weil es ein Problem gab. Und dann hat sich das aber resettet und dann bin ich nichts an den Zimmer gegangen und habe gesagt, Alexa, mach das Licht im Schlafzimmer an. Und dann ist das Licht unfassbar gleissend hell, hat das mein Zimmer erleuchtet, viel zu hell. Platz Nummer eins der Top drei Fun Facts über die Hamburger Wohnung von Florentins WG ist, wir haben eine Badewanne unterm Fenster. Ja, mega. Und das ist richtig geil, weil du kannst, während du in der Badewanne bist, aus dem Fenster schauen, du kannst die Sterne sehen. Oh Gott, das ist das Beste. Das ist unglaublich geil. Problem? Mitbewohner. In der Badewanne ist man ja in der Regel nackig.
Nicht alleine. Äh, was? Jetzt ist man aber über dem Fenster. Das Fenster ist so ein bisschen milchig, aber wenn man es aufmacht, natürlich nicht. Aber ich denke mir immer schon, es ist für Außenstehende, also es geht direkt auf die Straße raus, es ist schon so ein bisschen sexy. Selbst wenn ich durch so ein Milchfenster mich da morgens räkel und ich räkel ausgiebig unter der Dusche. Ich hör den einen oder anderen Pfiff schon auf der Straße. Ja, man muss sagen, aber es ist problematisch, also es ist Karriere, es muss in die Karriereplanung mit allem berechnet werden. Also du darfst nur einen gewissen Grad der Prominenz überstreiten. Es sei denn, du bist dir die Halle vor und da ist alles scheißegal. Da ist alles scheißegal. Wow Wow, Referenz kennt man gar nicht von dir. Naja, wo wir gerade dabei sind, Aretha Franklin ist gestorben. Ja. Kannst du kurz noch mal für die anderen sagen, wer das war? Ähm, ja. Alexa, wer war Aretha Franklin? Sir John Franklin war ein britischer Konteradmiral und unhervorscher. Konteradmiral und Konteradmiral, ja. Das wussten viele nicht, aber sie war auch Konteradmiral und britischer Sozialforscher. Weisst du noch, kurz mal Zukunfts-Ufo. Ganz früher hast du herausgefunden, glaube ich, du warst einer der ersten Menschen, der mir das gesagt hat, dass Amazon sowas rausbringt. Und du warst sehr stolz darauf und hast gesagt, ja, und dann holen wir uns so ein Ding, ich hol mir so ein Ding und dann ist der unser dritter Host, weil mit dem kann man ja sprechen wie mit einem Menschen. Ja, das stimmt, bis du mir die Idee geklaut hast. Ja, und dann bauen wir den ein in unserem Podcast und dann, ein paar Monate darauf, kam dann dieses und Zukunftsflautin hat es nicht genailt, sagen wir mal so. Das war wie so eine, wie man diese Beiträge, die man kennt aus den 90ern, die das Jahr 2018 vorhersagen, wo alle mit fliegenden Autos überall rumfliegt. Und das ist auch das Jahr, wo man Pakete bekommt, die mit Drohnen werden die geliefert und so. Ja, ja, Flautin lag nicht so richtig genau, hat es nicht genau on point getroffen. Naja, ich sag mal, jeder hat ja so ein paar Ideen für Late Nights. Und jeder hat ja in seinem Kopf so die Late Night Show, die er selbst gerne machen würde. Und bei mir war eben immer die Idee, Sidekick ist so ein Alexa-Kolben, aber mit so einem kleinen Trenchcoat und so einem Hut. Und eine Zigarette? Nee, keine Zigarette. So ein kleiner Qualmauf. Wir wollen Kinderfreundlichkeit offen halten. Das ist eine offene Kinder-Late Night. Und. Und dass man immer fragt, so, hey, erzähl mal einen Witz. Und dann erzähl er einen Witz und alle lachen, weil das Publikum auch komplett nur Alexas ist. Aber das war eine Zeit, in der das einfach Zukunftsgeplänkel und Roboterie war. Aber wenn man es dann da ist, ist es auch nicht mehr cool. Ich glaube, wenn jeder Roboter im Zimmer hat, ist es dann auch nicht mehr cool. Nee, ist nicht mehr cool, das stimmt schon. Irgendwann ist irgendwas vorbei. Ich nehme auch so, wenn du, also irgendwann werden die Leute anfangen, Flugstunden zu nehmen. Also du hast dann so ein Auto. Ja, ich muss jetzt zum Flugunterricht. Dein Auto kann fliegen, du hast gar keinen Bock, heute Nacht. Oh, hast du Heinrichsen? Oh Gott, nee, nicht der. Der hat immer so einen schlechten Gedankenkanal, hat der an. Und ich muss da sagen, die Fahrlehrer sind ja auch immer so latent genervt, obwohl sie, wenn, wenn man jetzt mal in die Vergangenheit springt, so im 16. Jahrhundert, kann man sich nicht vorstellen, dass jemand in diesem Zukunftsmobil so gelangweilt Leuten das Fahren im Auto beibringt, das Rasen beibringt, das Sausen. Ich dachte, du machst jetzt andersrum, dass der damalige Fahrlehrer in der Kutsche sitzt, völlig gelangweilt und einfach neben dem sein, ja, gib mal ein bisschen Gas, hier links, linker Huf vor rechter Huf. Brr, brr. Wir hätten hier rechts gemusst, kein Problem, wir fahren so langsam, dass wir noch die Chance haben, dass wir noch in zehn Minuten die Chance haben, rechts abzubiegen. Du kannst auch keine Fehler machen. Schulterblick, irgendwann in dem Bereich, wo der Schulterblick nötig gewesen wäre, wirst du schon irgendwann Schulterblick machen, weil es vergeht so viel Zeit. Machen die Pferde die Ausbildung oder der Kutscher? Eigentlich machen die Pferde ja das Hauptteil. Gute Frage, gute Frage. Und der Fahrlehrer hat dann immer auch selber nochmal so Seitenzügel, mit denen er auch selber nochmal eingreifen kann. Warum hat eigentlich nicht der Fahrlehrer auch ein Lenkrad? Das ist nicht nötig, weil er kann das Auto ja abrupt zum Stehen bringen, dann ist sein Lenkrad völlig irrelevant.
Ich fände es viel besser, wenn er auch ein Lenkrad hätte.
Wie in diesen Fahrzeugen, die es bei Star Wars gibt, in der Wolkenstadt, wo dieses sehr symmetrische Fahrzeug und die haben links ein Cockpit und rechts ein Cockpit und beide haben ein Lenkrad. Aber das ist, und dann habe ich diesen Gag mal irgendwann gemacht und dann meinte er, das ist ja gar nicht so lustig, weil Flugzeuge haben ja auch zwei Lenker und seitdem mache ich diesen Gag auch nicht mehr, habe ich mir vorgenommen, weil das stimmt. Moment, wie zwei Lenker, Flugzeuge haben auch zwei. Okay, links in drei, zwei, eins, eigentlich könnte es auch einer von uns machen, wenn man ganz ehrlich ist. Tatsächlich, ja, aber im Cockpit gibt es ja auch, Co-Pilot und Pilot haben ja beide ein Lenkrad. Also diese Lenden... Ja, natürlich lenkt nur einer, aber der andere kann, es da auch, Cockpilot und Pilot haben jetzt beide ein Lenkrad.
Also diese Lenk... Lenkt nur einer von denen.
Ja, natürlich lenkt nur einer, aber der andere kann, wenn er sagt, nö, kann er einfach das Lenkrad festhalten, doll, und dann kann der andere versuchen, der stärker ist, gewinnt. Also der stärker ist, der kann entscheiden, wo es lang geht. Ich muss gerade dran denken.
Ich war früher jedes Jahr mit meinem Vater im Urlaub in Italien.
Und da gab es dann noch immer so, gibt es hier in Deutschland wahrscheinlich auch so, Sachen, die man sich mieten kann, so verschiedene Fahrradspielereien, die man sich mieten kann. Und dann leitet man sich ein Fahrrad, dann leitet man sich mal ein Tandem, dann legt man sich okay, all in. Und irgendwann haben wir auch so dieses Auto gemietet. Also das Fahrrad, das fußbetriebene Auto. Ja, mit dieser Ha-oh, Ha-oh, mit dieser Hupe, die immer die gleiche ist. Es ist immer Papu, Papu. Und du hast vier Räder und sitzt da, dann gibt es das für zwei und das für vier. Und dann gibt es die mit vier... Sorry. Okay, pass auf. Und dann haben wir da zu zweit getreten einfach und treten da einmal durch unseren italienischen Urlaubsort und alles kein Problem. Irgendwie ist es natürlich ein bisschen anstrengend, du musst dich schon ein bisschen reinhängen, aber zu zweit haben wir uns dann schon viel geschafft. Der Trick ist, du musst derjenige sein, der weniger, der weniger doll trampelt. Pass auf. Und dann nach zwei Stunden Zeit abgelaufen, haben wir natürlich ganz pünktlich wieder zurückgegeben und der freundliche Italiener, der den Wagen wieder angenehmt, nimmt den so zurück und meinte so, oh, Moment mal, ich sehe, da war die ganze Zeit die Bremse drin bei ihm. Und wir haben zwei Stunden lang dieses Ding durch Italien getreten, mit der Bremse drin die gesamte Zeit. Und es war einfach so rückblickend, wow, einfach komplett gar nicht gelaufen. Holy shit. Das ist einfach lustig. Das ist, wenn du so in deinem achtzehnten Lebensjahr merkst, so, nee, du kannst auch beide Beine benutzen. Einfach so völlig unnötig. Ich hätte die ganze Zeit so Club-Up hier hinten noch in der Hose dran. Das ist die ganze Zeit 18 Jahre lang. Seit 18 Jahren. Weird. Aber der Trick ist doch bei diesem es ist auch wie im Tretboot Tretbootprinzip. Der Trick ist doch, du musst so tun, als würdest du genauso viel Gas geben wie der andere. Ja, natürlich. Aber eigentlich tust du nur so und hast dem anderen von vornherein das Gefühl gegeben, eigentlich mitzutreten. Ja, interessant. Hey, was hast du so erlebt? Ohne Scheiß, wir haben uns lange nicht getroffen. Ich habe ein Bild von dir aus dem Urlaub bekommen, wo ich kurz dachte, ich war kurz, bin ich dankbar oder erschrocken über diesen Einblick in deinen Urlaub, du hattest so einen Strohut auf, wo ich mir immer denke, wer kauft in so Urlaubsorten, in diesen, also wer kommt auf die Idee, sich so einen Strohut anzuschaffen, weil niemand findet die gut, niemand findet die sexy. Aber du musst verstehen, ich bin im Urlaub ein völlig anderer Mensch. Also jegliche Ironie lege ich ab. Weil ich finde, man muss auch mal Urlaub von seiner Ironie nehmen. Und einfach mal sagen, weißt du was, ich scheisse einfach drauf und kaufe mir auch so einen Strohhut und schaue mir auch irgendwie so eine Rock'n'Roll-Band an, wo der Sänger aussieht wie George Lucas, scheiß drauf, scheiß einfach, so und dann einfach mal durchziehen und einfach mal nicht sagen, lustig, lustig, lustig, sondern einfach mal machen, einfach mal ganz dumm auch schön Reiserummi-Cup am Strand spielen und die Hälfte der Steine verlieren, einfach mal das durchziehen, einfach mal auch zu Ende durchziehen. Naja, ich will nur die Entscheidungen, die getroffen wurden, verstehen, bis an deren Ende irgendwann dieser Strohhut stand, weil ich mich die ganze Zeit frage, das sind diese Hüte, die man kennt, von Strandpromenaden, von diesen typischen Geschäften, wo man sich auch, wer geht da rein? Meistens ist es nur, wenn man Geld wechseln muss oder wenn man was verloren hat. Es ist selten die Entscheidung, ah, da gehe ich rein, da sehe ich gerade etwas, was mir gefällt, was ich kaufen muss. Es ist meistens Notenverschuldigung. Die Sache ist die, ausserhalb des Urlaubs kannst du Dinge machen, die du sonst nie machst. Und das ganze Jahr überdenkst du dir eigentlich ein Strohut geil, aber ich bin zu cool, was sagen die anderen, was sagt die Carolina und so. Und dann machst du es nicht. Aber im Urlaub, und deswegen gibt es ja so viele Leute, die sich drüber lust machen, wie Leute im Urlaub aussehen, diese klassischen deutschen Touristen mit weissen Socken und Sandalen. Das ist doch gerade der Sinn des Urlaubs, dass man im Urlaub scheiße aussehen kann. Das ist doch völlig am Thema vorbei, wenn man sich darüber lustig macht. Du solltest die Leute beneiden, wie hässlich sie sind, wie hässlich sie sein dürfen, wie hässlich sie sein können, einmal im Jahr. Urlauber sind das Schlimmste.
Deswegen ist der Trick auch nicht, in große Hotelanlagen zu fahren oder Campingplätze.
Der Trick ist, weg, weg von Leuten, die Urlaub machen.
Weil Urlauber benehmen sich ja genau so, dass sie die Idee von Urlaub einfach mal sein lassen,
einfach mal so sein, wie man ist.
Aber Menschen will man nicht ertragen, so wie sie sind.
Menschen sind schon ganz gut mit ihrem Zynismus, mit ihrem Zynismus Fellmantel um sich herum, wo niemand reingucken kann, wo sie sich benehmen, wie man es von der Gesellschaft erwartet. Ja, total. Aber ich glaube, man muss diesen Zynismusmantel auch mal abnehmen. Und ich bewundere Leute, die rund um Touristen arbeiten. Ich glaube, das ist wirklich das ekelhafteste Berufsfeld der Welt. Animation die mit Touristen arbeiten. Animation, schlimmstes, das Buffet machen, das Hotelzimmer kümmern, grauenvoll. Ich habe Animation noch nie verstanden, weil deine Jobbezeichnung ist, Leute zu ihrem Glück zwingen. Wenn Leute mitmachen bei dir, bei Animationsprogrammen, dann wollten sie ja Spaß haben im Urlaub, wussten aber nicht wie, weil sie alleine nicht auf die Idee gekommen wären. Ich verstehe nicht, Leute, die am Animationsprogramm in irgendwelchen Hotels teilnehmen, ich verstehe nicht, was deren Plan war für den Urlaub, wenn Animateure die dazu bringen mussten. Also dieses in Urlaub fahren und dann so und was jetzt?
Ich habe tatsächlich, ich nehme mir immer viel zu viel für meinen Urlaub vor. Ich nehme mir fünf Bücher mit, ich nehme mir drei Rummikub-Spieler, ich wollte Ocarina of Time durchzocken auf Nintendo 3DS in meinem Urlaub. Ich bin auch nur bis zur Hälfte gekommen, weil ich mir so viel vornehme, weil ich dann nicht dieses, ja, und was machen wir jetzt? Das ist dann immer so unangenehm, da habe ich keinen Bock drauf. Und deswegen nehme ich mir wahnsinnig viel vor. Aber letzten Endes auch zu viel. Aber ich weiß noch, ich war lange an einem Campingplatz, wo es auch Animationen gab. Aber ich habe da immer nur zugeschaut und habe mir währenddessen ganz intensiv überlegt. Einen runtergeholt. Und ich habe mir intensiv überlegt, weil ich wollte Star, ich fand Star Wars so geil und dachte, ich drehe den neuen Star Wars, aber ich muss es leicht verändern, dass die Leute nicht merken, dass es Star Wars ist. Und ich dachte mir, was könnte ich machen? Und meine erste Idee war, ich drehe den Film komplett unter Wasser. Schwarz-Weiß, ja, okay. Weil anstatt dass die Jedis, dachte ich mir, also die heißen ja nicht Jedis, sondern die heißen dann E-Day oder Jedis oder Baby, Babys, die heißen Babys, die können nicht so Machtsachen machen, sondern die können in so einen schwerelosen Zustand eintreten. Und dann schweben die so und das dreht man dann unter Wasser alles. Also schwer zusammenzufügen, aber das geht schon. Oh ja. Und dann dachte ich mir, Lichtschwert ist die geilste Waffe im Universum. Ich finde sie geil, aber was kann man tweaken? Und dann bin ich auf Lichtpeitsche gekommen. Genau das gleiche Konzept, man hat auch so einen kleinen Kolben in der Hand. Ja, mit Traumschutz-Surprise. Genau, da kam es dann. Da kam es dann. Das hatte ich damals schon mit acht Jahren, während, wie heißt, von DJ Bobo der, nicht Chico Rita, Chihuahua. Hey Chihuahua. Vor allem, also wirklich, diese Animateuren, diese armen Seelen hören das ja den gesamten Tag. Die ganze Zeit Chihuahua, nur der eine Song. Du drehst ja wirklich durch. Aber es erinnert mich ein bisschen an meine Filmidee, die man auch nie drehen kann, weil es geht darum, dass die Erde einen Gravitationsausfall hat und alles rumschweht. Der Film dauert vier Sekunden. Oh, tot! Nee, nicht tot. Genau, es bleibt bei denen, die sich festhalten konnten irgendwo. Und ich will zu den Leuten ... Moment, aber sorry, die müssen gegen die Fliehkraft der Erdrotation dann ankämpfen, oder? Ja, ja, genau. Von welcher Kraft? Ja, klar. Also die ist ja nur noch, das ist die einzige Kraft, die da ist dann noch. Okay. Ja genau, und der Gravitationsausfall ist ausgefallen. Und dann will ich bei so einem Ladenbesitzer sein, dem vorging schlecht, aber jetzt ging es ja allen Leuten schlecht, aber er konnte sich zumindest festhalten, das heißt, ihm geht es besser als dem Gros der Gesellschaft. Und diesen Film würde ich gerne mal sehen, aber wird nicht niemals realisiert werden. Also ich weiss nicht, ob ich jetzt irgendwie Kickstarter Kickstarter soll oder so, weil es ist ja auch teuer, die ganze Zeit diesen Gravitationsausfall zu drehen. Aber vor allem sämtlich, also zwei Bevölkerungsgruppen überleben, die, die sich rechtzeitig festhalten konnten und Leute, die zu der Zeit im Töten in einem Gebäude waren. Einfach die beiden sind die auserwählten, die an seiner Decke hängen. Oder so Kletzschuhen, so großen Kletzschchuhen. Und das sind auch die ersten, die auf die Idee kommen, Moment kurz, wir können mit Klettschuhen auf der Erde gehen, lass uns alles mit Klettschuhen machen. Und dann beginnen die Leute halt, so verschiedene Lösungen zu finden. Und so heißt der Film auch, Klettschuhe, Riesenklettschuhe. Und dann fangen die an, den Boden so aus Klettverschluss, mit einem Gegenteil von Klettverschluss zu belegen. Und die anderen nehmen dann diese grossen Schuhe und dann verkaufen die die für sehr viel Geld. Und ich weiß noch nicht, ob dieser Ladenbesitzer sich diese leisten kann oder ob der für immer in seinem Laden bleibt. Wird man dann sehen. Klettverschluss ist glaube ich auch die Zukunft, oder? Also ich glaube, wer auch immer das erfunden hat. Ich gehe mal davon aus, dass jede Person, die irgendwas erfindet, immer denkt, das wird alles verändern. Also es gibt ja auch so legendäre Atomkraft-Was-is-was-Bücher aus den 80ern, wo dann irgendwie drin stand, ja, in jedem Bügeleisen wird ein Atomreaktor drin sein oder sowas, wo man zurückblickt. Wo man denkt, U-Boote, das war's. Ja, genau. Dinge, die betrieben werden, wo man sich vorgestellt hatte, alles Dinge, die tatsächlich betrieben werden, U-Boote. U-Boote und ein solcher Flugzeugträger bei den USA. Ciao, ciao, ciao. Aber das stimmt. Ich glaube, Klettverschluss dachte mir, Leute, jetzt ist alles besser. Und es ist eine der wenigen objektiven Verbesserungen, gegen die man sich entschieden hat, weil uncooler. Also immer noch binden wir uns die Schuhe mit Schnürsenkeln, weil es cooler ist. Aber ist es zeitintensiver? Das macht keinen Sinn. Du stolperst drüber, Menschen stolpern drüber, die gehen manchmal auf. Das ist doch nie passiert bei Klettverschluss. Tatsächlich hat das echt eine krasse Kraft. Wir haben ja für gute Arbeit, Jonathan Kocellny, haben wir auch mal da, wo ich so einen Klettverschlussanzug hab und da gegen so eine Wand renne und mich da so dranpinne. Und das hat auch echt gehalten. Wir mussten es dann aus technischen Gründen anders machen, aber es ist wirklich, dass es auch das Körpergewicht auch einfach halten kann. Ich denke mir nur, wer verleiht solche Klettverschlussanzüge? Wessen Job ist es, zu sagen, was machst du beruflich? Ah, komm mal kurz ins Nebenzimmer, ich mach kurz auf. Und da hängen zehn Klettverschlussanzüge drin. Und was macht dieser Laden, seitdem es keine gute Arbeit mehr gibt?
Ich finde, das war so ein Laden, der hat sich sehr spezialisiert auf uns.
Weil ich meine, ob du jetzt so einen Laden aufmachst, der Fidget Spinner verkauft,
im nächsten Monat dann Vaporizing-Artikel verkauft,
oder halt einfach auf einen Artikel, den du jemals verkaufen willst,
einmal diese Klettwand, bis sie jemand kauft.
Dann haben wir auch irgendwann diesen Maussketch gehabt, wo jemand uns Mäuse gekauft hat, die wir dann benutzen konnten und die er danach aufgenommen hat. Aber die hat er quasi so in advance gekauft. Der hat wahrscheinlich total expandiert, der hat gesagt Ah, Martha, das wird das Geschäft in Zukunft, lass uns noch hundert weitere Klettverschlussanzüge kaufen. Und sobald der Truck da war, ja, wir hören leider auf mit guter Arbeit.
Das war's.
Aber jetzt nur noch Frozen-Joghurt.
Du hast kein Urlaub, du hast durchgearbeitet.
Ich habe durchgearbeitet, aber meine Nachbarn haben Urlaub gemacht.
Meine Nachbarn von oben drüber,
die ich ja nicht kenne. Das ist ja das Wichtigste.
Du wohnst ja, also wenn ihr in einem Mehrfamilienhaus wohnt, einfach darauf
achten, dass ihr eure Nachbarn
dieses distanzierte Verhältnis nicht grüssen. Wenn du anfängst, wenn du einziehst und dich vorstellst, Fehler, dann bist du direkt im nächsten Level, dann bist du so ein Level zwei Nachbar. Das gleiche passiert, wenn du am Briefkasten jemanden triffst und anfängst mit ihm zu sprechen und dann immer Gegenfragen stellst, immer reinkommst mit so einem wie geht's denn und wie war arbeitmässig. Schrecklich. Auf gar keinen Fall machen, weil du bist direkt im nächsten Level und das Ding ist, du kannst dich nicht wieder downgraden. Du bist dann in dem Level gefangen und musst mit dem dann weitersprechen und dieses Level pflegen. Das willst du ja nicht. Und daran habe ich mich immer streng gehalten und ich bin klassischer Level-1-Nachbar. Kennt man nicht, sieht man manchmal, der Vermieter hat noch nie was von mir gehört, hier könnte die Heizung ausfallen, ich würde mich wahrscheinlich nicht mit dem Vermieter melden, aber das ist mir sehr wichtig und trotzdem ist es dann dazu gekommen, dass vor meiner Tür mein Nachbar stand und gesagt hat, ja wir fahren jetzt in Urlaub und ich dachte mir, was will er mir jetzt sagen und dann hat er mich tatsächlich gefragt, ob ich auf seine Pflanzen aufpassen kann. Du dachtest, was kommt jetzt? Hund, Tochter, könnt ihr bitte auf mein Trampolinzimmer aufpassen? Könnt ihr bitte aufpassen auf meine Pflanzen? Oh, komm schon. Pflanzen? Alles ist cooler als Pflanzen. Aber diese Frage alleine, das setzt so viel voraus, weil du kannst nicht Nein sagen. Das musst du doch wissen. Du bist gerade in so einer sozialen Falle und du willst niemand sein, der soziale Fallen aufstellt. Und das hat er gerade in dem Moment getan, weil meine einzige Antwort ist natürlich dann ja. Ja, aber interessante Frage, glaubst du, es gab in der Geschichte der Menschheit schon mal jemals jemanden, der gesagt hat, Entschuldigung, können Sie auf unsere Petunien aufpassen, einfach zweimal in der Woche gießen? Nö. Nee. Nö. Sonst was? Okay, dann müssen wir die alle wegschmeißen.
Ja. Okay.
Ja, vor allem warum bin ich der Go-To-Ansprechpartner
in der Welt. Das macht mich schon ein bisschen Sorgen.
Stefan, ich will dir nicht zu nahe treten, aber die haben
wahrscheinlich das gesamte restliche Gebäude
durchprobiert und du bist der einzige,
der nicht arbeitet.
Über mir ist eine WG, wo jemand
drin wohnt, der heißt Von irgendwas.
Das wäre mein Ansprechpartner. Also der hat schon, sein Namen gesagt, der ist für alles mehr geeignet als ich. Gut, über mir wohnt jemand, glaube ich, der mittlerweile gestorben ist, also schon sehr alt, also entweder sehr alt oder gestorben, also nicht der richtige Ansprechpartner. Aber naja, gut, er ist zu mir gekommen und ich dachte mir, ja, was soll schon passieren? Und dann hat er aber erst gesagt, ja, du müsstest ja ungefähr jeden Tag hoch und die Pflanzen gießen. Welche, sorry, aber ganz kurz, in welche Pflanze der Welt muss jeden Tag Wasser bekommen? An welchem Ort der Welt regnet es einmal am Tag? In keinem. Ja, genau, Tropen, so Regenwald-mäßig. Naja, die waren für zwei Wochen weg und ich habe dann zum ersten Mal mich hoch in die Wohnung. Das ist ja schon spannend. Ja. Du willst wissen, wie die wohnen. War alles sehr, sehr unspannend und dann haben die gesagt, haben die mir vorher eine WhatsApp geschrieben und haben dann gesagt, wir haben alle Pflanzen in die Badewanne gestellt. Da dachte ich mir, okay, das ist cool, das macht es mir auf jeden Fall einfacher. Und dann kam aber noch dieser Nebensatz wie, ach ja, und die anderen Pflanzen stehen auf dem Balkon und die bitte jeden Tag gießen. Und dachte ich mir, okay, das ist schon sehr übergriffig, aber gut, ich mach's trotzdem und dann bin ich auf den Balkon gegangen und der ganze, der ganze Balkon war voller Pflanzen. Ich hab ein Foto davon machen müssen. Ich hab's gesehen, ich hab in einer Instagram-Story gesehen, es ist erschreckend. Der ganze Balkon ist voller Pflanzen gewesen und die alle zwei Wochen, wo die weg waren, waren mindestens in Köln 34 Grad, top 39, 40 Grad, die ganze Zeit war komplett blauer Himmel und die Sonne hat genau auf diesem Balkon geschienen, jeden Tag und ich wusste, ab Tag eins die Pflanzen sind verloren, die Pflanzen sind verloren, nicht nur die, auch auch die Nabanewanne. Alle Pflanzen. Keine Pflanze in Köln lebt auch mehr. Weil es ist hier wie so Brachland, wie König der Löwen, wo es gar und so lebt. So sieht Köln mittlerweile auch aus, weil es auch ein bisschen wärmer ist. Und dann war der ganze Balkon mal wirklich unfassbar heiß und ich wusste, dass sie es nicht schaffen werden. Ab Tag zwei waren die auch alle schon tot. Und dann habe ich halt weitergetan, weitergemacht und so weiter. Und irgendwann kam dann die Frage, sollen wir dir aus der Normandie einen Rotwein mitbringen oder lieber einen Weisswein? Und dann habe ich gesagt, ja, dann kommst du ja auch nicht mehr raus aus den Normandien. Dann dachte ich, jetzt komm, jetzt gehe ich auch all in. Dann habe ich gesagt, ja, ach, so ein schöner Rotwein wäre nicht schlecht. Und dann haben sie mir tatsächlich, kamen sie dann aus dem Urlaub, sind zu mir gegangen, um sich zu bedanken für meine tolle Arbeit, haben mir einen Rotwein aus der Normandie gegeben und einen Käse, einen kostbaren Käse aus so einem Camembert und sind gegangen. Und dann dachte ich mir, das kann nicht euer Ernst sein. Nach dem Resultat wollte ich mir das geben und dann hat er den Sass gesagt, ja, ich war jetzt noch nicht oben und hab's mir angeguckt, aber vielen Dank schon mal. Ach du Scheiße. Seitdem, das ist jetzt schon mittlerweile zwei Wochen her, seitdem habe ich nichts mehr von denen gehört. Nichts mehr. Und das ist jetzt... Du, kann auch dran liegen, dass du in jedes Buch onaniert hast, aber man weiß es nicht. Nee, ich gehe auch nicht mehr so aus dem Haus. Ich gehe nicht mehr, ich verlasse nicht mehr so diese Tür. Seitdem sind alle Roller die ganze Zeit zu, mit so Brettern auch. Ich lasse auch dann teilweise die Post in meinem Briefkasten, damit die denken, ich bin gar nicht da. Ich will ja meine Spuren verwischen. Das ist das Problem. Das ist auch das Problem, du willst kein Level aufsteigen mit Nachbarn, weil wenn du die enttäuscht, du wohnst bei denen im Haus. Ja. Es ist dann vorbei. Das ist eine Geiselhaft direkt einfach. Ja. Ja gut, und das war halt deren Urlaub jetzt. Und jetzt können wir nach Hause kommen, alle Pflanzen sind tot. Ich stelle mir nur so vor, wie du dann, das könnte dann so das Ende der Folge sein, dass du dann irgendwie so durch den Flur gehst und dann gehst du über den Hof und dann ist so die Biotonne einfach so randvoll, so ein riesiger Stapel Pflanzen einfach oben drauf. Tschieze! Oder der Schrei vom Balkon runter. Sie geben mir Camembert und Rotwein und dann hört man nur die Treppen, Treppen, Treppen, Tür. Tschieze! Ja, naja. Aber so ist es. Macht man nichts gegen. Aber die hatten hoffentlich einen schönen Urlaub.
Aber ich würde selber, wenn ich Pflanzen hätte, im Leben nicht auf die Idee kommen, meine Nachbarn zu fragen, ob die sich darum kümmern wollen.
Vor allem, was ist mir denn wichtiger, meine fucking Pflanzen oder dass fremde Leute jeden Tag in meiner Wohnung sind?
Also da habe ich doch wirklich überhaupt keine... Ich meine, du, gut, deine Nachbarn sind große Podcast-Ufer-Fans, weiß ich, aber jetzt mal unter uns.
Was hast du in der Wohnung alles gemacht?
Also, zum einen, irgendwann war ich so sauer über dieses Angebot, dass ich angefangen habe, Pflanzen einfach auch wegzuwerfen, weil es waren auch so viele Pflanzen. Erstmal, meine erste Idee war, das ist die typische Truppe, die man kennt aus Sitcoms, jemand passt auf eine Katze auf, Katze stirbt, man besorgt eine neue Katze, die genauso aussieht. Das war meine erste Idee. Also dachte ich irgendwann, ich fahre jetzt einfach in den Baumarkt und kauf alles ganz neu in der Größe und stelle die wieder hin, wenn die halt wiederkommen. Aber das habe ich dann irgendwann nicht gemacht, weil ich dachte, das ist auch zu viel Arbeit und das ist fast mehr Arbeit, als einfach jetzt mein Leben lang deren Missgunst zu ertragen. Also habe ich das nicht gemacht.
Nein, in der Wohnung habe ich nichts getan, ich bin mit der Wohnung gut umgegangen. Diese alten Zahnbürstentricks und so, das will man ja auch nicht.
Sich ins Bett von dem kleinen Jungen zu legen und so, warum sollte man das überhaupt tun? Warum sollte ich das überhaupt sagen? Warum soll ich das jetzt hier überhaupt andeuten? Das macht man natürlich nicht. Was ist da? Was ist bei dir für ein Geräusch zu hören? Das war ein Moped. Ich versuche gerade so ein bisschen sizilianischen Flair rüberzubringen, ich habe das Fenster ein bisschen offen gelassen und hier hat es diese Hamburger Abendluft, man sitzt draußen, man sitzt in Cafes auf der Veranda, man hat so kleine Gerichte, wo dann irgendwie so drei trockene Parmesanstücke dann auch so am Teller liegen. Man geniesst den Abend, man wickelt sich in den Abend ein. Das ist so die Hamburger Kultur, ich find das ja auch toll. Hamburg ist laut, Hamburg ist laute Strassen. Die ganze Zeit, in Hamburg fahren auch andere Wägen, Automobile, Pkw. da fahren andere Vehikel. Anders als hier, in Köln sind es leisere Vehikel. Und das ist mir schon häufig aufgefallen, in Hamburg fahren lautere Wagen. Ich glaube, weil Leute mehr Geld haben, fahren die mit lauteren Dingern. Ich habe einen Trick entdeckt und ich frage mich, ob das nicht jeder macht. Also man weiß ja von den Dingen, die man so macht, nicht, wie viele Leute das machen. Deswegen Deswegen sage ich ja auch immer bitte, Leute, Statistiken, Statistiken, wie gut werden den Statistiken, wenn man einfach was macht und man denkt sich, wie viele Leute machen das auch, wie viel Prozent der Leute, also gerade so Sachen wie mit Erst Wasser, dann Zahnpasta, Erst Zahnpasta, sowas, einfach, kann ja sein, dass du der einzige Mensch bist, der ist genau andersrum macht. Achtung, folgender Trick. Macht ihr das auch?
Ich laufe geschwind auf dem Bürgersteig und komme an eine Person, die mir den Bürgersteig versperrt.
Das kann auf dem Bürgersteig sein, das kann im Supermarkt sein, das kann irgendwo anders sein.
So, und jetzt, während ich näher komme an diese Person, schleife ich absichtlich meine schuhe damit die person mich hört und aus dem weg geht nein machst du nicht konfrontationsfreudig das ist überhaupt ja aber das ist das funktioniert total gut und auch in supermärkten auch in supermärkten wenn jemand am regal steht und du kommst angedaufen ich fange wirklich wirklich wahrscheinlich lächerlich zu sehen, auch trampeln, weil gerade in Supermärkten kann man ja nicht so schleifen, weil der Boden glatt ist, richtig trampeln, einfach mal richtig aufsteigen, nicht so, ah, jetzt komme ich, sondern einfach so, als wäre das das normale Gehgeräusch und dann die Person, ah, geht zur Seite. Das ist konfrontationsfreudig. Nee, machst du über Geräusche. Überhaupt nicht. Du sparst dir ja gerade die Konfrontation. Keine Geräusche, nichts. Nein, du sparst doch die Konfrontation entsteht ja nur dadurch, dass der Konflikt nicht sofort gelöst wird und du sagen musst, Entschuldigung, Entschuldigung, Entschuldigung, können Sie kurz Ihren Kopfhörer? Auch Entschuldigung, nein, stehenbleiben, stehenbleiben, bis die Person von alleine weg geht. Ja, aber das ist passiv-aggressiv, das mache ich auch gerne, aber das ist schon passiv. Ich weiß, dass es an mir liegt. Nee, komm Stefan, dieses demonstrative
Oh, jetzt muss ich wohl stehen bleiben mit dem Augenrollen, mit dem...
Gar kein Augenrollen!
Um Gottes Willen, der Augenrollen. Ja, Stefan.
Nichts tun. Natürlich.
Ja, aber das ist schon passiv-aggressiv.
Ich bin auch nicht sauer darüber. Ich weiß, dass es an mir liegt,
dass es sowieso nicht besser hat, aber du willst
doch keine Konfrontation. Mir wird dann heiß
in solchen Situationen, ich fange an zu schwitzen,
ich weiß nicht, wie ich mich
verhalten soll in sozialen Interaktionen
und deswegen einfach lieber nichts tun und hoffen, dass die
Bis zum nächsten Mal. Du willst doch keine Konfrontation. Mir wird dann heiß in solchen Situationen, ich fange an zu schwitzen, ich weiß nicht, wie ich mich verhalten soll in sozialen Interaktionen und deswegen einfach lieber nichts tun und hoffen, dass die Person geht schon irgendwann weiter. Das ist mein Learning. Mach dir das auch so. Nichts tun, nicht auf die Schulter klopfen oder sowas. Manchmal, wenn man einen schlechten Tag, einen schlechten selbstbewussten Tag hat, dann sage ich mal sowas wie sorry und wursle mich direkt durch. Ich mein's nur mal eine theoretische Frage, aber wie erbärmlich würde man sein, wenn man als Fussgänger eine Fahrradklingel dabei hat? Also du hast eine Fahrradklingel so wie so einen Ring und dann läufst du und dann so bring bring und dann läuft jemand automatisch aus dem Weg. Würde zumindest den Helm rechtfertigen, den ich hier schon die ganze Zeit trage. Das würde zusammenpassen. Finde ich nicht so schlecht. Oder einfach wie diese, wie kleinen Kinder, die noch nicht Fahrrad fahren können, die diese Laufräder haben. Also da hast du zumindest die Rechtfertigung für die Klingel, weißt du? Also du läufst ja auch hier auf diesem Fahrrad. Ich finde es aber spannend zum Thema Helm, weil zum Beispiel Laufräder, niemand käme auf die Idee, auf einem Laufraden Helm anzuziehen, oder? Kinder haben auch noch Helme. Ach so, aber auf der anderen Seite, ich war zum Beispiel heute in einer Wakeboard-Anlage, wo man sich so ziehen kann von so einer Schnur und dann hängt man da dran und ein Wakeboard hat man sich total gefangen. Du bist ein neuer Mensch. Und da gab es dann auch den Moment, wo ich dann so dasteine und sage, ah, kriege ich einen Helm? Und die Person so, nee. Und dann so, ah, okay, das ist anscheinend eine Aktivität, wo man keinen Helm trägt. Also es gibt irgendeine Aufteilung von Aktivitäten, wo man Helm trägt und wo man Aktivitäten, wo man keinen Helm trägt. Und jetzt kommt meine These. Ich glaube, das ist relativ arbiträr, wie diese Aufteilung ist. Also zum Beispiel Bungee-Jumping trägt man Helm. Ja, ganz kurz,
ist das nicht schlecht?
Warum sollte ich das nicht schlecht?
Ich will mit meinem Kopf gar nichts berühren.
Gut, hast du beim Fahrradfahren auch nicht,
aber beim Fahrradfahren kannst du dich schützen,
wenn du hinfällst, weil du fliegst einen Meter
tief runter. Wenn du beim Bungee-Jumping
den Helm brauchst, dann bist du tot.
Wenn du den Helm brauchst, bist du tot. Ja. Du fliegst einen Kilometer von so einem Fernsehturm runter. Wenn du beim Bungee-Jumping den Helm brauchst, dann bist du tot. Wenn du den Helm brauchst, bist du
tot. Ja. Du fliehst einen
Kilometer von so einem Fernsehturm runter.
Aber so zum Beispiel ein Pilot trägt keinen
Helm. Also jetzt ein normaler
ziviler Pilot. Das ist richtig.
Der käme nicht auf die Idee, den Helm zu tragen.
Autofahren auch keinen Helm.
Und jetzt meine These. Ich glaube,
es ist unmöglich,
die Kategorien zu wechseln. Wenn du ab jetzt irgendwie keine Ahnung, wie gesagt, Bungee Und das ist ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr du ab jetzt irgendwie, keine Ahnung, wie gesagt, Bungie, du kannst nicht sagen, Freunde, ab nächstem Jahr machen wir keine Helme mehr. Weil alle sagen so, warum willst du die Helme abschaffen, was ist deine Intention? Es ist unmöglich, die Kategorie zu wechseln. Das stimmt. Anschnallen, auch so ein Ding. Ja, genau. Im Bus muss man sich nicht anschnallen. Warum muss man sich nicht im Bus, aber Reisebus anschnallen. Flugzeug anschnallen, Bus nicht. Warum das? Skateboard, nicht anschnallen. Und kein Helm. Helm, wenn man uncool ist. Ja. Oder professionell fährt. Auch BMX, Fahrradfahrer, ähm, nee, ist das BMX? Ich weiß nicht, diese, es gibt auch jetzt bei den European Championships, was so ein Mini-Olympia war, was ich wieder ganz toll fand, weil ich liebe den Olympia-Spirit. Und da gab's auch so wieder so eine Kategorie mit diesen coolen, diese coole Jungs auf Fahrräder. Jeder kennt diese zu kleinen Fahrräder, die nicht dazu gemacht sind, sich hinzusetzen, also ich nenne sie coole Jungsräder. Und diese coole Jungsräder, die sind dann auch gefahren und die tragen Helm. Aber nur, wenn sie es professionell machen. Und ich denke mir, wenn es jemand nicht braucht, einen Helm, dann die, die es professionell machen. Weil die können besser fahren, als die coolen Jungs auf den coolen Jungsrädern in der Halfpipe, weil die tragen keinen Helm. Diese Olympia-Leute haben auch keinen einfachen Job, zu entscheiden, was ist eine Trendsportart und was ist eine echte Sportart. Also jede Sportart fängt ja als Trend an. Also ich meine, als damals Baseball groß war. Riesending, jeder, oh Baseball, Baseball. Aber nach Indien 1 war klar. Nach Indien 1 war klar, ja, der Trend ist vorbei. Also zum Beispiel sitzt heute nicht irgendjemand da und denkt sich, wisst ihr was Leute, damals wart ihr alle gegen mich und in der Abstimmung habe ich mein Veto eingelegt. Aber rückblickend, war es denn wirklich so eine schlechte Idee zu sagen, Fingerboards kommen nicht in die Olympiade. Torwand schießen ist jetzt Olympisch. Und alle sagen, ja, ja, du hattest ja recht, du hattest ja recht. Solche Momente gibt es bestimmt Hunderte, wo Leute gesagt haben, wirklich, wirklich diese langgezogenen Gummidinger, die man so gegen die Wand dotzt? Nee, ich muss mein Veto einsetzen. Und dann sagt die Ukraine, nein, das wird grossartig. Oh, Ukrainian accent! Nailed it!
Tatsächlich frage ich mich immer, wenn die Discus werfen, warum nicht Frisbee? Warum nicht Frisbee-Weitwurf? Ist erstens einfacher weit zu werfen, also ergo spektakulärer. Und dann waren auch so Dinge, es sind wieder wahnsinnig nie passiert, da hat jemand eine Discus geworfen und der hat fast einen Fotografen erwischt. Weil der Fotograf hat aber, weil der hat es durch sein Objektiv geguckt und hat nicht den ranknahenden Diskus gesehen. Und der Reporter ist ausgeflippt. Nicht weil der weit geworfen wurde, sondern weil man sterben kann, wenn man vom Diskus getroffen wurde. Naja. Vor allem kann man nicht irgendwie das Ganze ein bisschen ökonomische Ansägen und Sportarten zusammenlegen. Zum Beispiel, lass uns mal zusammenlegen, Diskus werfen und Tonschauben schießen. Einfach mal die gegeneinander antreten können. Finde ich geil. Und dann bringt man da so eine Challenge rein. Nick, ja oder einfach, man legt die Schedules einfach so, dass man diesen, dann kann man das auch schnell durchrücken. Man kann das schnell durchrücken, die werfen und man muss den Diskus treffen und dann, wenn man den getroffen hat, dann ist, also dass man nicht diese Maschinen bauen muss, die diese Tonscheiben... Lächerlich, dafür hat man,... Hallo, ich bin der weltbeste Diskuswerfer und die Maschine macht das? Das finde ich super interessant. Was kann man denn noch zusammenlegen? Bogenschießen und Sprinten? Bogenschießen und Sperrwerfen. Ja, aber tatsächlich, Sperrwerfen wurde ja geändert. Auch da habe ich wieder dieses YouTube-Video gesehen. Und anscheinend waren die Speere früher anders, sodass sie gesegelt sind in der Luft, so ein bisschen.
So ein bisschen wie beim Skifliegen wurde ja auch seine Skis so positioniert, dass er so ein bisschen Auftrieb hat.
Beim Skifliegen oder Skispringen?
Nee, Skifliegen, da habe ich jetzt aber auch drauf geachtet, Stefan.
Und so gab es nämlich auch bei den Speerwerfern eine Art Wurftechnik, dass der Speer so schief fliegt, sodass er so ein bisschen Auftrieb bekommt.
Aber da haben die gesagt, das wollen die nicht und deswegen haben die die Speere geändert. Es gab eine lustige Kategorie Synchronspringen, wo das Pärchen, was gewonnen hat, haben sie dann irgendwann gesagt, war schon klar, dass sie gewonnen haben, die trainieren nicht zusammen. Das war nur Zufall, oder was? Die genau das gleiche gemacht haben. Waren das einfach Schwimmbadbesucher, die gleichzeitig die Treppe hochgegangen sind. Und die trainieren nicht zusammen. Die waren Ukrainer oder so und die haben in verschiedenen Städten gelebt. Und irgendwer hat gesagt, na ja, wir haben uns zufällig getroffen. Genau, zufällig getroffen. Ja, genau. So wie Ukrainer zu sprechen, man kennt das ja. Und dann sind die gesprungen, runtergesprungen, haben sie zum ersten Mal gesehen, haben einfach gewonnen und es gab auch nur fünf Teilnehmer und dann hat, die Deutsche wurde zweite, die Deutsche und der Deutsche wurden zweite von fünf. Also dritter und vierter, es ist ein bisschen kompliziert. Und die haben Silber bekommen, wie Leute beim Speer werfen, die irgendwie gegen 80.000 andere aus der Welt irgendwie Speere werfen und die waren einfach fünf und die hat sich total gefreut über Silber, wo ich mir sage, nee, das ist eure Leistung steht nicht verhältnismäßig zu eurem Jubel, weil ihr seid Zweite geworden von fünf. Ist das nicht eher so wie so ein schlechter vierter Platz eigentlich? Vor allem, ich habe auch mal so einen Artikel gelesen, es gibt ja E-Sport, ne, und momentan ist es auch ein sehr großes Dota-Turnier und wahnsinnig krass und große Hallen füllen und so. Und da gibt es ja immer wieder so Artikel dann so, ist das wirklich Sport irgendwie, ich glaube irgendwo in Korea oder so gibt es jetzt auch als Schulsport, kann man auch E-Sport machen und sowas und Und dann gibt es dann immer mal wieder so Aufreizartikel. Wann ist das Olympisch?
Und da gab es auch mal einen Artikel, wann ist E-Sport Olympisch? Und dann natürlich die erste Frage in dem Artikel war, welches Spiel spielt man denn? Wii Olympia 2018. Wii Sport. Wii Olympia 2018. Das wäre doch das Beste. Einfach alles in Wii. Ich habe Gold im Bowling, im wie Olympischen Sportmodus. Aber ich denke mir so, das ist so eine dumme Frage, soll E-Sport Olympisch werden, weil egal welches Spiel du nimmst, irgendwann ist das Spiel alt und dann hast du bei den 2019en Olympischen Spielen, dann hast du Sonic auf dem Dreamcast, weil das halt irgendwann mal vor 20 Jahren als Olympische Sportart akzeptiert wurde. und dann hast du bei den 2019en olympischen Spielen Sonic auf dem Dreamcast, weil das halt irgendwann mal vor 20 Jahren als olympische Sportart akzeptiert wurde. Und dann hast du ja dann noch vier Nerds, die halt dann Sonic spielen. Es ist offensichtlich eine dumme Idee. Jede Schlagzeile mit E-Sport ist dumm. Top fünf Spiele, die nicht doof wären als olympische E-Sports Disziplin. Top fünf Spiele, die nicht dumm wären. Platz fünf, Mario Kart. Wäre nicht doof.
Ja, alle gegeneinander. Alle gegeneinander, alle gleiches Fahrzeug irgendwie, alle nehmen Yoshi, komm, alle nehmen Yoshi, außer die Jamaikaner. Hey, der hat auf meinen Bildschirm geschaut, hey, Schiri, der hat auf meinen Bildschirm geschaut. Disqualifiziert. Und schon wieder scheidet Joachim Graus aus der Schweiz aus. Er hatte leider auf den falschen Bildschirm geschaut während der ersten Runde und dachte, er wäre in Führung statt, deswegen führ er die ganze Zeit. Mein Controller geht nicht, mi controles no es fusiona! Escape, Escape-Klemmt. Ah, sehr schön. Virenscanner geht an. Ich hör nix.
Virenscanner geht an.
Ja, also ich weiss nicht, Mario gerade findet, die würde funktionieren, sonst vielleicht einfach auch nichts.
Ja, stimmt schon.
Aber das würde ich mir auch anschauen, das wäre schon echt gut, so die Besten aus der ganzen Welt.
Ja, finde ich ganz gut.
Wann ist denn die Olympiade wieder? Machen wir da mal was dazu, begleitend?
Ich glaube in drei Jahren wieder. Oh, echt ist das nicht jedes Jahr? Nee, alle vier Jahre, das ist denn die Olympiade wieder? Machen wir da mal was dazu, begleitend? Ich glaube in drei Jahren wieder. Echt ist es nicht jedes Jahr?
Ne, alle vier Jahre, das ist doch die Idee von Olympia.
Oh ne, das ist mir zu lang. Ja, ich weiß.
Kommt Fussball alle zwei Jahre und Olympiade dann alle vier?
Überleg mal, und da ist dann irgendwie 2023 oder sowas. Da kann man bestimmt mit einem Alexa reden in einem Podcast. Das wäre mal was. Ich bitte, der links über Regen kommt jetzt. Alexa, stopp. Alexa, stopp. Niemand interessiert sich dafür. Alexa, stopp. Es reicht. Sorry, aber man kann das. Du musst auch Autorität. Ich glaube, deine Alexa ist ein bisschen verzogen. Ich glaube, du warst in den ersten zwei Wochen, wo du sie hattest, ein bisschen zu locker, zu leger. Nee, nie. Zu nidi, würde ich sagen. Ich habe zu viel gebraucht von ihr, okay? Ich wollte zu viel. Du klammerst. Und jetzt klammert sie zurück. Ja. Bis sie irgendwann so anfängt. Stefan, Stefan, mehr Strom. Stefan, aktiviert mich. Stefan, heute 21 Uhr, Restaurantbesuch mit Katja. Wer ist Katja? Nur so eine Freundin, die habe ich hier, mit der studiere ich, die ist in einem Nachbarkurs, aber das ist nur so was ganz, das ist auch für die Uni, müssen wir was besprechen. Alexa aus. Ja, da kann sie auch nichts mehr machen. Ich habe den Sketch getötet, indem ich Alexa ausgesagt habe, oder? Ja, das stimmt. Na gut, du hättest ja und machen können. Ja, ich habe ja und gemacht. Ja, ich bin aus und, hättest du machen können. Ich bin tot und. Ein kleiner humoristische Einschub für alle Improffans. Ist dir mal aufgefallen, dass wenn man pfeift, um Aufmerksamkeit zu erzeugen, dass man immer macht, das ist der Intervall, den man machen muss. Terz, oder? Wenn du sagst, hey, wir machen mal was jetzt, komm mal, komm mal kurz drum, hey, Jonas, den Ball weg. Ist ein Terz? Es ist eine eine Terz, eine grosse Terz, und du kannst es nicht anders machen. Du kannst nicht sagen, hey, Jonas, Ball weg! Das kannst du nicht bringen, oder? Es ist sofort, hey, es ist, Jonas, der Ball muss jetzt weg! Es klingt sofort, als ob du einen Vogel imitieren willst. Du kannst, es ist nur dieser eine, dieser eine grosse Terz erlaubt, um Opferzettel zu erzeugen. Und das ist ein Polyphon. Jesus. Ja, aber alles andere klingt nach zu viel Effort. Hey, Flonten, weiter geht's. Stefan! Sofort. Er ist aus der Ukraine. Er ist aus der Ukraine. Ach ja, das ist mir einfach... Ach Stefan, du, ich wollte noch eine Frage an dich stellen. Ja, ja, ja. Du, ich habe richtig Bock auf unsere Tour, wir reisen quer durch Deutschland und wir müssen leider sagen, es gibt schlechte Nachrichten und zwar Mannheim ist ausverkauft. Mannheim und Hamburg ist ausverkauft, es gibt aber noch viele andere Termine, wo es noch Karten gibt. Gut als Geschenk, gut als Andenken, ihr müsst gar nicht hingehen, kauft einfach nur. Mir ist aber aufgefallen, ich habe am 19.11. Karten für Jim Gaffigan, kommt nämlich nach Köln. Und ich habe Karten für ihn, und da haben wir auch einen Auftritt in Mannheim. Also wir spielen gegen Jim Gaffigan. Nee, ich glaube, ich gehe zu Jim Gaffigan. Weil, also, nichts gegen dich, aber ich habe die Wahl, dir irgendwie eineinhalb Stunden zuzuhören auf der Bühne oder halt einfach Jim Gaffigan. Und dich erlebe ich ja noch ein paar Mal live. Nicht, dass du schlechter bist, aber dich erlebe ich ja schon noch ein paar Mal. Aber kannst du es denn vielleicht irgendwie Livestream so zu mir, dass wir das dann irgendwie auf die Wand werfen und einfach so eine Second Screening machen.
Ich werfe es euch noch mal auf die Wand und werde es vielleicht leicht kommentieren. Ansonsten immer lustige Instagram-Stories bei Stefan, folgt ihm Stefan Tiziosi, Esteban Tizios immer auf Instagram gerne gesehen und auf Twitter. Und auf jeden Fall, kommt es ruhig, wir freuen uns sehr auf euch, kommt vorbei, wir machen eineinhalb Stunden. Dürfen wir eigentlich schon mal ein bisschen teasern? Es gibt nämlich, vielleicht haben wir auch ein paar kleine Zuckerstückchen in unserem Merch-Shop im Angebot. Vielleicht haben wir uns da ein paar nette Sachen überlegt. Haltet die Augen offen, ihr werdet aber auf jeden Fall auch hingewiesen. Ansonsten, wir freuen uns sehr auf euch und es wird eine Herausforderung und ich bin gespannt. Wir sehen die Welt. Wir sehen die Welt, wir kommen ein bisschen rum, wir kommen in Osten. Nach Wien, nach Wien, nach München, nach Wien. Nach Wien. Stimmt. Wien war rückblickend Fehler, vielleicht, weil es stellt sich heraus, es hören drei Leute in ganz Österreich. Ja, aber dafür haben wir jetzt verlässliche Daten, wie viele Leute in Wien hören und Geld haben und Zeit haben. Und das war es doch wert. Und das war es doch wert und darauf kommt es doch überhaupt an. Daten sind eh die neue Währung, sag ich. Daten sind die neue Währung.
Florian, die hat mir Spaß gemacht.
Ich freu mich schon, nächste Woche wieder was von dir zu hören.
Du, auch nächste Woche bin ich auf der Gamescom,
aber ich bin in Köln, das kriegen wir auf jeden Fall hin.
Vielleicht können wir ja live von der Gamescom senden,
das Podcast-Uvo auf der Gamescom.
Warum nicht? Ansonsten wünsche ich dir noch einen schönen Abend.
Ich wünsche dir auch einen schönen Abend.
Wir sind wieder zurück, es geht wieder weiter,
wir heben weiterhin ab und auch jetzt, macht's gut.
Nächstes Mal ohne Latenz und richtig cool.
Ciao, ciao!
Und vielen Dank an Mark für das Intro.
Macht's gut, ciao!